thank you nate many people have cut back
on going out to dinner these days but
you can still get that restaurant
experience
in the comfort of your own home damon
gordon the director of culinary
development at lowry's prime rib
joins us to tell us more tell us about
this setup lowry's
primer is it's an experience how are you
guys making it easier for us to get it
well yes obviously with everything
that's going on you know we wanted to be
able to
offer uh you know what our dining
classic experience is it for the guest
at home
so obviously with that you'll get the
vintage dressing for a classic
um spring bowl salad uh cc browns fudge
to make the sundae
seasoned pepper the tins for the
yorkshires
and a uh a thermometer to make sure that
you cook the beef correctly
um and we just really wanted to be able
to do that for the
for the guests at home so you would get
a certified angus beef
uh prime rib whatever size that you
wanted
and then a selection of the sides and
then also
included in that we have a qr code so it
shows you how to carve the beef
step by step of that recipe some history
on the company which has obviously been
around for
many many years and also recipes to
reheat the side dishes
and your leftovers like i mentioned so
if you don't eat it all on that night
you can make
uh we've got two or three really good
interesting recipes there to use up the
primer
i was going to ask you now how do i make
it
just with that quality that laurie's is
known for but like you said you have all
of the instructions in there
we've got all the sides of my favorite
the cream corn at lowry's
how much does this entire package cost
well the special that we're doing for
valentine's you get a third rib
uh and you get one of each of the sides
it's like 239
delivered to your door so and you get
like i said you get the step-by-step
recipe like you were
that we were cooking it for you but
you're going to take the
uh the grandeur of it and you're going
to cook it yourself from preheating the
oven
making sure the beef is at the right
temperature how to heat the corn how to
eat
heat the spinach if you want to do that
via
microwave or in the pan as you can see
on the tv
we give you all those all those
directions and options that you are
going to have a
true larry's classic experience happen i
love that you guys include
the yorkshire pudding i have that here
look at that prime rib
um and and everything is neatly packaged
this
is so easy to get all you have to do is
go to
lorries at home.com
to get yourself your own authentic
lowry's meal this looks fantastic and it
looks like a great experience for the
entire family to cook together thank you
so much
thank you very much indeed enjoy we will
be
right back